wait speaking of strip you were you went
to my show yes I did I was like you said
you were going to come and then I didn't
know if you really went you did oh no I
was on top of it I bought tickets to
your last show of The Residency cuz I
knew that was the one that was really
going to give I was like they were all
going to give but I was like I know that
you're going to whip out the classics is
is that me sobbing at your show is that
the one wait is that the one that I did
happier than ever is that the did
happier than ever you did sober yeah
that's for real fan uh yeah and then you
did I didn't know this but so I had of
course memorized the set list before we
got by the way I brought like 13 14 of
my friends I'm not kidding we went as an
gay army to your show so we went and I
have like memorized the set list and I
knew at the end when you were going to
stop before the oncore so I was like I
can go to the bathroom at this theater
the men's room was in timb two I'm going
and I hear just what if I told you and
I'm like she's not doing a Moment Like
This she had never done A Moment Like
This in the show she surprised did A
Moment Like This I peed faster and
harder and then you were running and I
was sprinting back and also it's like
you're pretty let's say hydrated when
you're in Vegas you know what I mean
there was a lot of stuff that was drunk
so I had to go so bad but I was like let
me make it back for a moments like this
and then I got there and I sobbed I love
the video I know you're so I was really
crying hard me anytime you sing I cry oh
my gosh well never I never sing that one
generally just yeah I know and that's
why I was so surprised you were doing it
because I know you traditionally don't
and so then I was like come on I'm
literally screaming to my friend Patrick
like we have to go we're not washing our
hands like it was I will cop to being
unhygienic when it comes to getting back
to if I'm running back in somewhere yes
yeah no it's just or it's usually my kid
at a movie they're like I've got a PR
are you serious I know but you put on
such an incredible show I mean obviously
it was you guys you're you're adding new
shows right you um we are that's
announced right yes
yes yes we we are we did we added a a
couple I think but um I was like I'm
always like what am I allowed to talk
about I always
[Music]
[Applause]
forget thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home